c'est lui c'est génial vous avez
peut-être déjà des messages passaient
sur les réseaux sociaux le brut en gros
j'ai lancé une messagerie et je
demandais aux gens de témoigner
anonymement par rapport au harcèlement
qui n'avait subi les boules voulu
l'appeler pour un compliment victoire
sur le
web attendait vite faire recevoir
quelques messages
ça n'est pas du tout au nombre de
messages que j'ai reçus le téléphone n'a
pas arrêté de sonner pendant une semaine
et je pense qu'en tout j'ai reçu plus de
1000 messages je peux plus je n'en peux
plus je suis allé à l'école éric
lavallée lendemain les chiffres
officiels disent que cette somme il
enfants se font harceler en france ça
très 5 à 6 % des élèves mais andré moi
je pense que c'est encore beaucoup plus
élevé puis la quantité des messages que
j'ai reçus sur les pauvres
[Musique]
je trouve qu'on parle pas du tout à
séduire seulement en france du coup
aujourd'hui je vais vous raconter
l'histoire de dinars
[Musique]
elle avait 14 ans elle est aimée garé
proche de son grand frère
[Musique]
vos cuisines et madame aujourd'hui à la
cuisine aux petits prévoir un petit pour
les barbecues qu'est-ce que vous avez
mis comme marmelade dessus
[Musique]
on m'avait six ans d'écart mais je les
voyais pas à moi les six ans d'écart fin
on était vraiment proche je le parlais
tout elle parlait tout fin c'était
vraiment c'est assez visionnaire quand
même
foulée veulent être sûrs gogh liste
j'ai griffe miu
mais moi j'aimerais bien aussi latin qui
n'est du coup pas la voir se vexer ça me
faisait rire et du coup ils rigolaient
finale mais on rigolait on rigolait pas
mal
[Musique]
on a pratiquement les mêmes goûts
musicaux du coup on se retrouvait
beaucoup dans sa faune s'envoyer des
playlists des gens sont là écoutez etc
et puis quand je rentre à la maison du
coup ben défend vous êtes des petits les
petits duo sur des chansons deux ans
j'ai beaucoup en gêne certains jours
sont en danger le par exemple
comme on sait
car tout le temps
[Musique]
ça fait rigoler
et comme vous m'avez pris elle était
très mature pour son âge elle avait déjà
un regard sur des sujets sur la
politique sur sur plein de choses qui
est déjà bien ancré en elle et
ouais a été très très intelligente a
volé très président de la république
je suis très proche de ma mère va se
réciter très proche de ma mère à la
maison parle vraiment de tout il n'y a
pas de tabou c'est très ouvert on a une
confiance absolue on nous tous
[Musique]
en 2020 à une équipe mulhouse pour faire
ses études loin de cherry et du coup
loin de sa petite soeur dina elle est en
quatrième sa mère commence à sentir que
10 ne va pas trop bien mais au début
dina lui dit rien finalement elle lui
avoue qu'elle a des petits soucis avec
ses copines son comportement commence à
changer elle ne veut plus aller à
l'école elle fait genre qu'elle est
malade pour hâter les cours et le soir
elles laissent des messages sous
l'oreiller de sa mère en la suppliant de
ne pas l'amener au collège ort les
premières causes deux soirs seulement
c'était parce que c'était une très très
bonne élève elle avait des super bonne
note et elle posé beaucoup de questions
en classe ça ça avait le don d'agacer à
certaines personnes mais je pense qu'on
a tous déjà vécu ça à fond on
connaissait la personne qui pesait trop
de questions et après on souffle quand
apostrophe question ça nous garde dans
la classe à la famille attend la sortie
tu vas voir mais ses dessins elle
n'arrivait pas à s'exprimer en classe
parce que dès qu'elle ouvrait la bouche
ça sifflait partout en fait tout le
monde l'anglais tour d' insulte et honda
traité tunes et rohmer encore toi encore
elle
on la prenait en photo en cachette ou
quelqu'un qui est assis derrière elle il
m'a tapé sur sa chaise pendant une heure
mais sans s'arrêter et ça tous les jours
m'a jamais dit que ça ce que cette durée
toutes leurs du court
et
changer de place aussi j'ai en fait je
suis allé voir un prof c'était pas
vraiment un la leur en coûte parents
profs et je lui ai dit ce qu'elle peut
changer de place vous l'avez mis entre
deux personnes qui l'empêchent de
et m'a dit oui mais vous savez nous
faire un roulement fait tous les trois
mois tous les six mois je dis oui mais
d'accord mais là c'est moi qui vous
donne en tout on parle pas de roulement
vous l'enlevez elle en a marre j'en ai
dit non il fallait le dire médina dit
mais je voulais 10 et après il a changé
de place
dans les couloirs on va la bousculer on
va la frapper on va l'insulté
[Musique]
même quand elle rentrait basse a
continué avec les réseaux et avec what's
up avait snapshot y avait ferré à tous
ces réseaux là donc on verra ce qu'elle
a dû faire ce qu'elle a dû bloquer les
appels et messages et pendant une
certaine heure et à lui débloqué juste
le soir
après avoir fait ses devoirs et dans un
laps de temps précis et à la bloquer
tous les contacts enfin on pouvait pas
la paix dans la journée avec le numéro
de mon père la mère et moi qui fouleront
l'a contacté hier dans la journée
et et
et et pourquoi tu as peur comme ça
le surfeur même sa chambre elle parlait
plus trop c'était c'était bizarre face
n'est plus la dynamique on avait connu
sa mère s'inquiète beaucoup pour zina et
quand elle entre en troisième son
harcèlement devient encore plus violent
elle avait un groupe de copines de base
elle était way 6,7 je pense va commencer
à dire qu'à s'intéresser au
courant et jbt que peut-être qu'elle
aimait les filles et les garçons en même
temps et que ben voila c'était elle
[Musique]
donc assez confié à son à son groupe de
copines et à deux de ce groupe là qu'ils
ont fait croire qu'elle est un local
islam originel
je pense qu'ils ont soufflé le chaud et
le froid et dîna c'était je t'aime moi
non plus et dîna tombait toujours dans
le piège
et comme il connaissait son point faible
est son point faible entre du mais
c'était sa sensibilité donc ils ont
elles ont joué de sa revue quelques
semaines on dit mais tu crois vraiment
qu'on qu'on était à mon resto et moi
jamais de la vie
[Musique]
tu les une ignominie de la société et du
coup ce groupe là bas a propagé au sein
de la classe et du coup ça s'est propagé
dans le collège que c'est rapide à
partir de là y avait déjà le fait qu ben
du coup ce soit l'intello le fait que ce
soit la lesbienne est en fait après tout
ce qu'elle faisait c'était critiqué
c'était on parlait de surtout le maître
un jogging saoul insulté peut mettre un
pantalon à ses insultes et enfin c'était
vraiment pour tous ses faits et gestes
qu'elle se faisait à critiquer
[Musique]
allez vive et
merci
elle avait une première tentative en
mars elle avait pris les médicaments et
du coup elle est restée à l'hôpital une
deux semaines je crois
je suis rentré le jour où elle allait
rentrer aussi à la maison et du coup je
lui ai vu je les ai vus quand je suis
rentré je vais je vais beaucoup parler
elle m'a dit oui mais t'inquiète pas je
referai plus ça
je sais pas pourquoi j'ai fait ça je le
referai plus ses copines étaient au
courant parce que on a appris aussi très
récemment que ma soeur elle leur disait
pendant qu'elle faisait sa tentative de
suicide elle leur disait je vais faire
ma tentative de suite je suis en train
de le faire et quand elle s'est
réveillée après ça
elle a reçu aucun message à rien ses
copines n'ont rien fait m'avait montré
un message ouais parlait soit ça et dean
a parlé avec lui les filles se parler
entre elles mais elle faisait comme si
elle comme si dinara tel n'existait pas
en fait dans cette conversation
et elle m'a montré son téléphone elle
m'a dit qu'est ce que tu entres qu'est
ce que tu lui qu'est ce que tu comprends
et je lui dis bah je comprends qu'elle
elle te lisent mais elles ont décidé
entre elles peut-être cazaux un groupe à
côté que tu connais pas et qu entre
elles se disent venir c'est ça vous fait
comme s'il n'était pas là après ça on
l'a beaucoup sur
[Musique]
enfin bon après je reste à la maison
quand même assez longtemps et on l'a
beaucoup beaucoup soyez besson avait
peur moi je sais que quand j'étais en
bas je monte je mettais une alarme et je
montais toutes les 20 minutes ou alors
j'ai appelé dans les escaliers pouvoir c
était toujours là et est encore une fois
j'avais l'impression de la punir parce
qu'elle était constamment surveillé et
je pense ça doit être encore une
pression pour elle mais c'était pour
elle et c'était pour sa sécurité
[Musique]
elle reste à la maison je crois une ou
deux semaines après son hospitalisation
et le jour même où elle retourne au
collège on nous a appelé pour me dire de
venir la chercher elle voulait plus trop
aller en cours enfin à chaque fois il
s'est trouvé des excuses et essayé
d'esquiver un peu l'école alors qu'elle
adore ça c'est juste que les gens ne
voulait pas les voir en fait
ma soeur a reçu une lettre enfin en fait
elle leur a fait une lettre pour leur
dire prenez moi dans le groupe je me
sens mal dé toute seule je m'excuse de
ce que je vous ai fait même si je sais
pas ce que je vous ai fait je jure elle
n'aimait pas être celle ma soeur et
voulait les mettre entouré ces personnes
là ont répondu par une lettre jamais de
la vie entrepreneurs dans le groupe tu
essaies tu te tuer une fois t'as pas
réussi mais la prochaine fois on me
donnera des liens pour pour te montrer
comment tu peux tu peux réussir à
susciter t'inquiète pas tu mérite pas de
vivre enfin que des choses comme ça
c'était vraiment horrible
finalement en juin 2021 dina termine le
collège c'est les vacances elle part au
maroc elle a l'impression que ces soucis
sont derrière elle
en septembre elle va recommencer dans un
nouveau laissé on ne serait pas avec ses
harceleurs
[Musique]
elle fait sa rentrée elle est super
excitée de retourner en cours mais un
jour elle recroiser harceleuse personne
ne sait exactement ce qui se dit ce jour
là mais en tout cas le 5 octobre dina
non peuplée de sa vie
vers
2h 3h du matin je reçois un appel de ma
mère
qui me dit ah ça lui rien ça va avec une
voix bien réveillé et je suis dit oui
mais lesquels heures lundi les trois
heures puis mais pourquoi tu m'appelles
m6 mais tu dors je dis bah oui les trois
heures et m dubert rendors toi je suis
dit maintenant tu m'appelles à 3 heures
du matin c'est qu'il ya un problème et
et là je sens que sa voix étrange et
instinctivement je suis compris qu'ils
reprennent avec ma soeur et elle m'a dit
c'est dina et c'est exactement le même
schéma que sa première tentative de
suicide et il me dit avant de racrocher
faut que tu rentres à la maison
j'ai besoin de tours est là en fait cela
à mon père est né lui dire que mes
crimes avait dit que son car il avait
lâché et tu crois mère m'appelle est là
l urée le téléphone
[Musique]
elle répété j'ai plus fille j'ai perdu
ma fille j'ai pu lire et je rentre à la
maison
[Applaudissements]
devrait pas être là elle devrait pas
être là c'est pas possible mais je me
dis c'est pas possible
c'est un truc de fou ça me rend fou ça
me rend vraiment fou
n'a rien à faire ici
même les cours j'arrive plus du tout
assure c'est horrible je
j'arrive plus pour tancer j'ai toujours
voulu faire psycho et je me suis donné
pour revenir à la fac de psycho de
bordeaux et
c'est hyper intéressant c'est juste que
mon esprit n'est pas il n'arrive pas je
n'arrive vraiment pas j'arrive plus à
rien du tout vraiment de base les
psychologues dans l'armée on est là au
vu des événements je pense que je vais
me tourner vers
psychologue dans la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse pjj pas
[Musique]
du coup l'âge de partir à bordeaux est
en fait la première fois que j'ai
rencontré rennes pour faire ce reportage
c'était aussi à bordeaux donc ça fait un
peu une boucle qui se termine et là ce
soir on va dîner avec ses colocs qui
sont aussi en psychologie et du coup ça
m'intéresse un peu de voir leur point de
vue par rapport à ce qu'ils pensent
qu'ils devraient être faits sur le
harcèlement en france et pour éviter
qu'une tragédie comme celle dédiée à ces
reproduise
si les deux côtés on parle pas elle si
c'est pas censé utiliser des deux côtés
parce que on sensibilise beaucoup pour
le harceler ce qui est très bien mais
faut aussi je pense sensibiliser les
harceleurs comme quoi c'est pas normal
en fait y'a rien de normal à mettre à
part quelques uns à illies à la normale
et je pense que tant que des deux côtés
il n'y a pas la prévention qu'il faut ça
va ça va continuer qui fait la
prévention dès le début fin dès la
première alerte ben vrai ça
ça peut éviter beaucoup de choses quoi
ils doivent attendre qu'une famille ça
rendait passe à la télé en fait pour
festi suffisamment c'était qu'une
famille demain soir c'était la 19e
trois autres appuis c'est quand y en a
encore eu après après tout ça il ya là
c'était quand la semaine dernière elle a
eu une petite fille c'est aussi
mais tu dis mais ça s'arrête jamais avec
les réseaux sociaux il ya un moyen de
crédit mais continue à harceler même
quand t'es pas physiquement avec la
personne je peux jamais bloqué une
personne entièrement si le regret un
comptable comme un conte c'est le donc
ça ça va deux bonjour je me demande si à
l'heure actuelle mais des fois parfois
je me demande l'état d'esprit des gens
qui ont harcelé ma soeur à l'heure
actuelle qu'est ce qu'ils se disaient ce
qu'ils dorment correctement est ce que
ils ont envie de venir chez nous pour
s'expliquer est-ce qu'ils sont
totalement différents s qui s'en veulent
est-ce qu'ils ont conscience de tout ce
qu'ils ont fait je sais pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour nous
c'est trop tard mais que dit n'allez
plus là mais pour les autres il faut
qu'il ya des choses qui soient mises en
place il faut qu'ils aient des des lois
qui sont votées contre le harcèlement il
faut que que les équipes pédagogiques
des établissements elle soit formé il
faut limite mettre des des personnes qui
sont formés spécialement des
psychologues ou je ne sais pas qui sont
ceux qui sont formés spécialement pour
ce genre de problèmes de harcèlement
dans les établissements et qui s'occupe
vraiment que de ça il faut vraiment pas
que ce soit c'est un sujet encore trop
tabou en france et je comprends pourquoi
si c'est un sujet tabou mersen scolaire
le 24 février 2022 le parlement a enfin
dotée reconnaissant le harcèlement
scolaire comme un délit la peine
pourrait grimper à 10 ans de prison si
l'effet qu'on lise la victime à se
suicider par contre rien ne change pour
la famille de dinars car les faits se
sont passés avant le vote de la loi
dans dix ans je trouvais vraiment
ses qualités mode ou le manque
le son de ta voix qui m'appellent
je sais bien que c'est pareil
ton odeur sur tous mes vêtements
tu sais bien ce que tu me piquer tout le
temps pas le disputent le fou rire nos
peines nos messages nous a pelleté jeter
des blogs qui ne voulait rien dire
moi elle me faisait toujours sourire la
douleur qui me consume lentement me
rappel à chaque instant qu je
n'entendrais plus jamais t'avoir
mais mon coeur ne veut pas le comprendre
il me crie qui voudrait te voir et
chacune y je t'attends
tu sais j'aimerais tellement savoir si
de la produit pouvait me
si tu l'as où tu pouvais comprendre que
sans toi + moi de sens
si vous ou l'un de vos proches sont en
train de se faire harceler lie à numéros
gratuits vous pouvez appeler c'est le 30
20 pour recevoir du soutien le
harcèlement est encore trop tabou en
france c'est pour ça que vous avez
probablement été si nombreux à me
laisser des messages vocaux et c'est
aussi pour ça que je voulais faire cette
vidéo aujourd'hui si cette vidéo vous a
intéressé vous pouvez vous abonner à
notre chaîne brut pour voir plus de
coupons et n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer un
message si vous voulez que je parle
d'autres sujets qui vous tiennent à
coeur
[Musique]